i wish i could bring home more money
hey
[Applause]
ever since i was a little boy i would
always beg my mother for a little
brother
but you know we were broke so awkward
before all can we
all it's live
everyone sitting at home just think that
tv just messed up
[Applause]
do you want some of mine you
if you're looking for a place to relax
with an old lady look no further
new york's hottest club is spicy
around runs back okay does
does like 360.
what is a human kite it's that thing
where you tie a string to a [ __ ] and a
windbreaker
and then run through a field
that's fine dana deep just driving
wasn't dana digging doug's garden no
dylan dick not garden
guys come quick it's dana what happened
she's dead
dana's dad's a doornail what'd you do
she was diving into a deep ditch and did
a double flip
then a deep did you dive in wasn't dana
digging dog's garden no dylan dick's
like garden
oh it's so bad plants added flag in a
list of countries
yeah i'm gonna get all the permits
proper permitting and i need evidence
got it wait you don't know what evidence
ah right on yes hit me
next to my desk is a picture of a female
politician bella abzug is that scary
face funny hat gap tooth or bill
clinton's wife funny hat
funny hat on the back of it is a key
taped to it and then that opens my
bottom drawer and my desk
get it
set sail for africa all
of africa zimbabwe kenya
ghana tanzania tribesmen
this time
i'm starch
awesome thanks for coming
hello you know something like that yeah
hello
hello how do you feel mr david
how'd you feel mr harry the fanning
yourself with a palm
between rounds
i found i found such a
deep deep connection here
you can feel it in your stomach
tell your translation that you want to
see
africa all of it from angola
to jamaica take it in your hand
and grip it lightly
like that oh that's good now
first take a deep breath and blow
don't suck and then put your fingers
oh god i lived with the eskimos many
years ago
and they used to plunge their faces into
the snow
get back on sam vicente take it to the
ten then switch to the four
four five north
where you belong
[Music]
at this time of day it's gonna be jammed
seems so i don't know like he's a good
person
you know like he's i don't know he just
seems so cool
what is wrong with you you
sorry sorry sir sir and i fell for the
oldest trick in the book
we're not doing it again i'm sorry
immediately following my birth the
midwife proceeded to slap my buttocks
and then my father bent down and
whispered into my tiny here
you can cry now and open up your lungs
uh
you know what you should be ashamed of
yourselves
mr dwyer were you aware of funds for
tennis court
that ms knope requested that was denied
by mr ron swanson that was later
approved
by ben wyatt no what point comes after
deuce
wipe
it is true however that i do have a
tickle in my anus
um badass nothing
i'll try it again okay okay
this place has everything asbestos
lupus the magazines at supercuts
dan cortes
now on top of everything else you're
being evicted what
[Laughter]
ah that's a good one why is it called
insert
oh because it's been in some
you know what you're talking about
because you oh cause you did it in
prison too
i did not do no such thing i didn't have
to
because i killed for mine with these
i'm sorry you're really having a good
time there
needless to say this place has
everything skunks
k-fobs cookie crisp damn cortex
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm gonna run out and this place has
everything
kiwis spud webs
[Applause]
jazz was born in new orleans
or as it's correctly pronounced nerlins
and then from nerlins
wow as the only married couple here
could say we've got a little advice for
you keep it tight
you know what i mean she
biff what happened to you
you have my spare key in your apartment
right yes in the kitchen drawer
oh man i think we should pretend
like we're old people and practice when
i sit down to do my dirty business my
gonads hang
in the water the handle
[ __ ] me sorry about that the angle
in the water what surround sound means
is that
right over here
[Laughter]
folds
hey
[Music]
oh [ __ ] all right